you're from Florida Rick Ross has been a
on aew a lot recently have you ran into
him backstage I have sweet guy nice guy
um very professional guy and the what
you see from him that's like him they
don't rehearse they just go out there
and just spit but also he's an
Entertainer so that's what he does so
when it comes like to the Bow Wow
situation that was just the Entertainer
he'll just spit and that's what they do
as entertainers like Shaq when he came
and he performed with me before going
out he was like I said don't embarrass
me he's like don't you embarrass me and
he's an Entertainer he said he was your
taxing partner yeah so my first match
with Cody Rhodes and red velvet he
looked at me dead in my eyes and said
they're gonna eat and like anything I do
out there because I'm an Entertainer so
yeah and he was like so you don't
embarrass you yeah I was like what like
but I thought that was funny but that
was your first match ever ever that's
why I'm saying like people are watching
that was my prior to that I had an
off-grid match where I was a face
and it was like five minutes and that
was the only match I've ever had ever
prior to my debut and most people have
plenty of house shows and and so many
reps and like have perfected I didn't
know I was turning Hill until well I
thought it was going to be a face and
the first night I went out there to do
my promo they're like yeah you're going
through the Hilton tunnel and I was like
wait so does that mean I'm a hill like
yeah you're a hill I'd love to be a heel
so it's fun it's [ __ ] yellow it's fun
I love it I would like I want to make a
child cry in the audience every night I
go out there that's what I would want to
do I flicked some kids off but I have a
kid right no no no if somebody messes
with my kids I just want to do something
to their hero okay that makes them cry
oh well you gotta mess with them too
yeah you got to like yo that's why your
mom's cheating on your [ __ ] dad oh my
gosh well have you seen mjf well Max Max
does it yeah no yeah yeah so you you
this whole this whole time you've been a
heel for the most part right yes that's
all I've been is a hill but I get
cheered and I'm like what the [ __ ]
because
so what was so talk about Shaq because
uh Shaquille O'Neal obviously is uh you
know the man but to be that's kind of a
that's a pretty wild first match you're
tag teaming with somebody who's not a
wrestler no but he's been in that in
that stage before at WWE so you're going
against uh Cody who's like the face of
the company yep how nervous were you I
wasn't nervous wow at all I think
because again I played college sports
and I performed in front of thousands of
people and I've done All-Star games and
things of that sorry to just you're
gonna get what you get and even when
like I've been out there and uh the
cheer shots or anything of that sort and
it's something I've never done before I
just I don't know like I have this thing
where it's like fight or flight and I'm
like Jade you know our fan how our fan
base is so you just gotta go out here
and do the best you can and it is what
the [ __ ] it is